apd und darauf schreibt sehr clever bot
nämlich ganz genau
hallo mein name plötzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video und
wegbereitende eingeblendet wir machen
heute einen youtuber von frank und zwar
nicht an irgendeinen youtuber sowie
ihren kämpfern im clever bord und wir
machen den von frank mit songs also ich
glaub es ist logisch ich habe überlegt
aus sowie kleine serie zu machen das
heißt ihr könnt mir jetzt verboten in
die kommentare irgendein youtube sorgen
schreiben denen ich das nächste mal den
körper bot verwenden soll
[Musik]
hab ich vorher schon so ein bisschen mit
dem clever bot geschrieben wie geht's
dir gut wir auch gut was machst du mit
dir schreiben ich esse ich auch der
care-o-bot schreibt einer weit mit mir
und ist gerade pizza aber leute ich nun
erst mal das lied fordert für den
heutigen verwenden werden und warten von
einem flug über der für seine dokumente
wortwahl und eine die grünen
die welt zugegen sind bekannt ist und
barack obama
wir fangen direkt mit der ersten stelle
und war nein ich fahre keinen wenn
saliba clever bord darauf antwortet er
nämlich du kannst nicht englisch gut es
ist ja auch deutsch schläger warum
schreibt er mir dass ich kein englisch
kann ich schreibe ich fahre keinen ben
war aber gut
leute wir machen weiter mit der nächsten
und ich fahre keinen täter zwar nicht
mehr mit du kannst kein englisch
du kannst nichts zu tun aber wir
schicken sie einfach mal ab und bekommen
hat anton barth für ein auto habe ich
du einen look like erbaute schiff zu der
telekom mit war später eigentliche
treiber range rover memory und dann
schreibt er power
power rangers
warum schreibst du power rangers fragen
was jeder dreiste blick trifft den wagen
komma wagen hat er doppelt gesagt und
darauf antwortet der clever bord ok
können wir machen cool können wir machen
dass jeder 13 blick den wagen trifft die
meinst du das lieber klare worte ich
jetzt wirklich mal weil ich weiß nicht
was er meint mit können wir machen bist
du ein junge oder ein mädchen ich
schreib mir einfach ich bin eine junge
vielleicht muss ich gern noch ein
bisschen im gespräch mit ihm erstmal
kommen ich bin ein junge ist geschrieben
und wir bekommen als antwort und wie
heißt er mit schreiben einfach abrede
und darauf schreibt wer clever bot
nämlich ganz genau das ist einfach okay
ich schreibe jetzt nein ich heiße
konkret damals schon ob er daraufhin
macht anderes antwortet und darauf
antworten und ich halte so wirken ist
und es waren leute nachher fotos und
denken ich weiß warum du sitzt im auto
das dem fußballer seine wild überhaupt
keinen sinn upgrade leute machen fotos
und denken ich sei fußballer und darauf
antwortet der clever worten nicht ganz
genau lässt sich erstmal mit ihm zeit
das ergibt keinen alten wendig hellseher
wäre ich sage vorher noch das noch
keinen favoriten klar beantwortet das
ergibt keinen sinn
ich könnte der clever roger 22 zoll
felgen im wert von 100 goldketten im
wert von 100 goldketten du kriegst
goldketten für 50 cent hat gefälschtes
aber
22 zoll felgen im wert von 100 gold
hätten darauf antwortet der klever
worten nämlich wie folgt das merke ich
dafür kannst du aber gut schreiben danke
wieso kann ich gut schreiben wieso kann
ich gut schreiben
clever worte verstehe ich jetzt endlich
gesagt nicht geplant wie du jetzt darauf
kommt ich dachte nur bezieht sich mit
dem eher auf den preis auf jonah
goldketten jedes mal den text schreiben
das machen nur noten dicker also kann
ich gut schreiben jedes mal male in den
text schreiben das machen würden würden
nur schreibens mai lief ein paar
sekunden später wird sagen auf antworten
erst mal mit einem smiley lieber clever
board also mal schauen was dort jetzt
antwortet ob ich jetzt eine note bin
oder nicht leute ach ja wo wohne ich
denn wer kennt nicht so eine tolle text
überleitung aber ich würde sagen machen
weiter mit der nächsten zeile aus dem
lied verpackt und doch nach 24 lieben
mond issues durch die stadt fahre tag
und auch nach 24 lieberose durch die
stadt wohl einzig endlich nacht und
statt apa red
da muss man nochmal lernen so ein
bisschen okay
ja
hab ich mir auch gedacht sich die line
gehört habe
range rover mansory jetzt kommen nämlich
zur hauptaussage des liedes und war vw
bulli kloster in the back of the world
[Musik]
wendekreis wie busfahrer wenn ich durch
die putz hatte der verschwiegene ich
gedacht auch nicht er wer redet von dem
wendekreis und dann rattert er durch die
haut dabei bin ich durch die hydra dann
heißt bei ihm da würd ich werd busfahrer
darauf antwortet der clever bot wie
folgt nein ich bin wenn ich bin und du
bist wenn du du bist
[Musik]
wo kauft nur luxusware kadewe doch meine
damen und herren ja dann sag doch nicht
was andere doch nie etwas anderes gesagt
oder nicht auf 700 ps räumen opel aus
dem weg so das ist dann auch schon die
letzte aussage für heute und war ja ich
kann mir das einfach nicht nur länger
geben weil ich in seinem teller nicht
alles gemacht hatte was er wollte was
schon kranke vergangenheit glaube ich
dass die familie meine damen und herren
es euch gefallen hat wie gesagt lasst
das schaffen wir auch andere lieder und
in die kommentare mit denen das nächste
mal machen sollte findet jetzt die oben
im mai die eigene clique auf jeden fall
nicht traut auf keinen fall da drauf
klicken da oben findet ihr auch mensch
doch eingeblendet und hier unten ein
anderes video
ja
und fliegt nicht aufs eis
oder doch